grand vision itself has always been you
know hey let's create a platform where
finding roommates and housing can be as
easy as just booking an airbnb right
like because today it's sort of this
very fragmented process where you
uncreates this you're on facebook or
you're you're trying to find mutual
friends to share this
very uh you know high risk uh you know
high cost contracts with people you
often don't know and so we thought okay
the best way to do this was uh you know
to build this app where you can swipe
left and right on you know roommates and
houses that's so like tinder
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking with colin tai about modern
living modern sharing of living
single-family homes and how people can
better find the right match for where
they will live
holland is the co-founder and ceo of
alco a platform that enables shared
living and any rental property the
platform invites people in search of
their new home and community to find
rooms to rent and allows for homeowners
to list available bedrooms in their
homes
we're speaking i'm from israel you're
from hong kong
even though i think we're both spending
most of our time in the united states so
an international episode at the very
least and you're working on some of the
most exciting spaces i think that we
have today and and you'll elaborate why
you're so excited by it but this idea of
living and and community living our
ability to
to sort of understand where we want to
spend our time to to have our room our
home and in the community we're going to
be with so you're taking it to the more
modern approach with alcove and i'm
excited to uncover in these 20 minutes a
little bit about yourself and and the
formation of alcove and why this is the
most exciting thing for you to be
working on right now so colin the stage
is yours thank you so much for being
here
absolutely we're really excited to be
here thanks for having me michael uh
yeah so you know just to really dive
right in right like uh really what
alcove is building is what we believe to
be you know the future of shared housing
and for me personally
uh you know the story began uh you know
a couple years ago when i was a duke i
was actually trying to find uh you know
roommates because it made things a lot
cheaper and realized that there were
lots of these you know big rental units
uh you know rents are pulling but you
know the hard part wasn't finding the
homes it was finding the you know the
actual roommates you know you have to
find a group of friends who have to have
the exact same you know location budget
living preference and they get everyone
to sort of commit to this
uh you know big rental contract all
together and even at school wherever it
had pretty similar preferences this was
still
yeah you know a very very time consuming
process for us and so um you know as we
sort of looked into this you know i i
met my co-founder patrick uh and you
know actually at a class at duke and uh
we realized this wasn't just a problem
for us uh it's actually a much bigger
problem and today
you know about a third of all american
adults live in some sort of uh you know
a roommate situation uh and more for
most of these people just like us you
know they can't afford to uh you know
they can't afford to live alone uh so
really there were two options to either
overpay for a studio apartment or to go
through this very cumbersome process of
piecing together this roommate group and
that's that's how we sort of decided to
go on this journey to
um you know reimagine uh the way that we
find shared housing and you know build
the future of uh you know room living
and hence alcove today
incredible and so as you're as you're
sort of
building the saturn you started how did
you envision alco from the get-goes
you're coming from this personal
experience what was the grand vision
that you were going towards
yeah and um
it's funny because i i think
the well the grand vision itself has
always been you know hey let's create a
platform where finding roommates in
housing can be as easy as just booking
an airbnb right like it's today it's
sort of this very fragmented process
where you're on creates this you're on
facebook or you're you're trying to find
mutual friends to share this very uh you
know high risk uh you know high cost
contracts with people you often don't
know and so really how do we make it as
easy as uh you know booking an airbnb or
booking an uber uh but i would say the
the journey itself uh and and the well
more sort of the the product vision has
definitely shifted uh a lot and so at
the very beginning we were sort of a
duke and uh you know there was very this
this very uh tight-knit community and so
we thought hey the best way to do this
was uh you know to build this app where
you can swipe left and right on you know
roommates and houses that's so like
tinder
and we we sort of went through this you
know three four month process in a
panera uh you know next next to campus
and we built this app and we were like
okay this is it you know everyone's
going to come and this is this this was
going to be the thing uh and
obviously
that wasn't quite the case uh and we
realized that actually you know people
did use it uh in a duke where everyone
was in this like college community like
you know it was actually a pretty viable
front uh you know we were able to
onboard you know a couple hundred
students uh mostly grad students uh who
were sort of in the same groups and we
were able to abort a bunch of department
buildings who were interested obviously
you know from the
you know real estate leads perspective
uh and then pretty quickly when we just
you know tried to expand this you know
to the rest of the city uh realized that
people didn't quite want to find
roommates the same way you know they
would find their weekend fates and so i
quickly rebuilt the app uh into sort of
a
uh weapon of shape system more familiar
uh you know zill-like interface which is
you know the way it actually is designed
today uh and so
you know you're able to
um you know very much so like looking
for an apartment looking for a a house
on zillow on apartments.com find you
know these beautiful single-family
houses uh with great compatible
roommates that you can get matched with
uh and sign a you know a per room lease
so you're not on the hook uh you know
with the rest of your room equipment so
that's that's sort of uh you know it's
you know to answer your question i think
it's sort of pivoted a a couple of times
from
uh you know just an idea
that you know people could get matched
uh you know on a mobile app uh into
these roommate groups all the way down
to this uh you know i think very
extensive uh you know search interface
where people can find you know roommates
and
bedrooms in a single platform
interesting
and so
if we're looking at sort of the consumer
behavior shift is it is there any
different expectations from from the
user's perspective either the roommates
or the the people that are looking for a
room in this new type of behavior as
they're searching for rooms or is there
something is there something new that
you're expecting them to take part in or
some new market education that you have
to to describe your lifting or is this
pretty pretty much straightforward for
anybody that comes into contact with
alcove
yeah and
and that's a that's an interesting
question and you know i think the way to
to think about it is you know first of
all how do people today right like
currently find uh five roommates right
like first of all yeah uh you know you
find you go and you go in zillow and you
sign the lease and take on that risk of
a full house and then you go on facebook
craigslistroommates.com and go through
this roommate process to you know vet
and
uh you know find these roommates uh
which is a little risky sometimes
because you've got to figure out if
they're financially worthy and
trustworthy to then split furniture
bills deposits with what effectively are
sort of like strangers and then
ultimately be on the hook for at least
so you know for us really um you the way
that our product had to match you know
the consumer
uh
you know had to solve how to solve the
consumer problem was to make it so that
it was
you know 100 times better uh where it
was super seamless and easy
uh you know for this entire process to
be done on a single platform and so the
way we've done it uh is we you know from
the search process where you're only you
know having to find and qualify for uh
you know the bedroom itself uh so you
know a third of the home uh and then
getting matched with the pre-vetted
tenant to a background credit income uh
you know credit verified and to signing
parent releases which means you're only
responsible for your portion of rent all
within the 40-hour period so that's
that's step one and then step two is you
know having your payments bills support
renewal options uh you know and chat
options with your roommates all on a
single platform uh so that you so that
we can essentially become this operating
system for all your housing processes
and so you know really what we learned
was um you know you know the incumbent
right like the way that roommates
currently do it today is this very
broken fragmented process that's
extremely painful and for us we had to
make it a single stop solution where
somebody do it within a 40-hour period
and tell me a little bit about about
growth here so you were mentioning sort
of the the initial onboarding but
obviously the plan is to to to continue
expanding and tell me a little bit about
the go to market strategies in in your
space how do you get both both sides of
the marketplace to to jump in especially
as you need there to be a mass of
a massive interest from both parties on
on any given location in order to launch
on that location right i mean it's a
classic marketplace problem somebody
enters the app you need to have
offerings in your own area so that you
can have a good experience
yeah that's uh you know
i think the way to think about
uh the go to market well first of all um
you know i'll talk a little bit about
how
you know yes both sides of these
customers come up platform but also who
these people actually are like on both
sides of the marketplace um you know
first of all
uh you know just to dive a little bit
into
what the market actually looks like
right like the problem that we're
fundamentally solving right is that
housing is unaffordable in america right
structurally speaking the median
american makes thirty thousand dollars
per year so can qualify for up to 800
bucks per month for rent and on the
other hand the median studio costs 1200
bucks a month so you need to make 43 000
to qualify so at the minimum there is
this sort of 40
dollar per year rent gap in the real
estate economy so people kind of afford
to leave alone people need roommates and
finding roommates terrible process right
like and this isn't just a college pro
and that's that was one of the biggest
learnings for us it's actually a much
bigger problem than that uh and you know
on that on the on the supply side on the
of for these properties right these
landlords you know what's what's been
happening i think the last couple years
with this institutionalization of single
family homes right like you've got
blackrock blackstone an american post
friend buying up these homes and driving
up uh you know what we're already uh
you know a pretty expensive housing
price so for the everyday real estate
investor right like there's this new
compression where you need to you need
to have a passive way to make more more
rent right like and so
you know that's sort of who we're
targeting on both sides right like it
really is the
the the
you know the 80 million americans who
are currently living in ship housing
because they counterfeit a little load
and and the you know these you know the
of single family owners uh who you know
need a way to make more money uh for the
single family houses and so the way
we're acquiring these
uh these customers are on both sides
right starting with the demand side
really starts with where people are
currently searching for housing so
you know a lot of people are on right
like on on zillow on apartments.com
looking for studios or you know single
family houses to you know for them to
live with a lot of these places um right
like is is where we distribute and
advertise our homes right and they see
very clearly this you know for example
in north carolina this 1500 studio
apartment and then this 700
uh you know bedroom option right it's
very clear for them you know saving
fifty percent there's something to work
you know then that's worth digging into
uh and and so a lot of our our traffic
actually comes in from you know what we
call partner platforms like these
partner real estate platforms and on the
supply side similarly right like they're
renting out their units on these on
these platforms and we're going in there
and and and sharing our story and
telling them about how we uh you know
how we're
you know you know a value added a great
solution for individual homeowners uh
and so you know
that's how we started and obviously
today uh this direct traffic uh word of
mouth organic which has been you know
amazing and that's sort of how we've
been growing a lot recently
so what is the offering today for alcove
sort of end to end besides the discovery
phase what what are their action items
or what other actionable things can
people do on your platform from the
moment that they discover a match that
that could be suitable for them
yeah absolutely uh and you know i gotta
talk talk about this from from the
perspective of both sides right starting
with the the
mod side so so for these roommates uh
you know first of all
uh it's it's naturally right like it's a
completely
unique search search experience right
because instead of you know going on
these uh
you know what we consider forum uh forum
channels right like craigslist facebook
groups uh where you're looking at
subleases and you know these uh you know
very fragmented roommate posts it's her
bedroom listings you know uh bedrooms in
these single family houses uh where they
otherwise cannot access so it's a
complete spectrum of these uh you know
beautiful single family houses that they
can they can actually apply to right
like once they've applied uh you know
they're they're completing background
credit income checks directly on
platform with integrated with transunion
uh for this to be done almost instantly
uh and then you know they're after right
like they're they're verified and so
they're let into this trusted platform
on alcove where they can meet their
roommate talk with their roommates uh
and see if there's a fit right like you
know they're they've got uh you know
these profile features where they can
upload their uh you know where they're
from where they go to school uh what
they like to do for fun and yeah things
like that right and so when they when
they've decided that hey like i i'm in
this trusted community i want to live
with these people they can sign lease
together and again this happens very
very quickly and these homes are
furnished uh these these shows come with
wi-fi these homes are um
you know pretty much you know everything
that's required for you to uh you know
rent with roommates is done on platform
uh and so that's that's what's offered
on on the roommate side on the supply
side right like on for landlords really
this is a one-stop solution for your
manage your entire single family uh
rental portfolio so you're you're
listing your your homes on alcohol uh
and then you're approving
applicants tenants uh you know directly
on on your phone and then uh you know
you're signing leases on one single
place and so it's a way for you to very
quickly and very easily you know earn 50
above market returns on average on what
traditionally is a uh you know a unit
that only families can rent and now you
can enable you know a
certain micro communities of young
professionals uh to to be in your
property and make some extra money at
the same time
fantastic fantastic so looping back a
little bit to sort of the wide
of alcove and and you're why i mean you
know you started this off with duke
based on personal experience but but
today you know not running the company
why is this still something that you're
so excited about whether it's you know
the opportunity in the market the
product itself the team i mean what is
it that really drives you
with with running alcove today
yeah that's uh
uh you know first of all there's a
really i say a lot of things uh you know
obviously you know every single day um
you know we're we're building alcove
with an incredible team uh and as we're
saying based in north carolina and so uh
we're really a a very mission driven
team
um that's focused on again building this
future of shared housing and so that's
for me very enjoyable uh just from a
personal perspective uh but really i
think on a bigger
on a bigger landscape right this need to
live together has really grown uh you
know very significantly and continues to
be this you know massive secular trend
right like from a structured perspective
there's really three key drivers of this
that we see every single day uh and then
for a high level first of all there's
five times many individual renters is
there a single bedroom unit so there's
this massive mismatch and second of all
we know it's going to get worse right we
need to build on average 300 000 new
apartment units every single year for
the next 10 years which has been done
once in the last three decades and
lastly right like we know roommate
groups are rated already this natural
solution right like 80 million america a
third of all american adults
live in as you know some sort of a
shared household
and you know for me personally
uh you know again i i'm in hong kong
right now i grew up here uh and housing
for affordability is something that's
i've always wanted to impact uh in hong
kong it's something that you know really
there's only one option really you have
to build more housing uh but in the us
we have this opportunity uh to really
completely revamp and restructure the
way that we rent housing with these
single family units uh
and you write like from a systemic level
like there's three there's three things
that we're really
impacting in this space every single day
you know first of all we're
fundamentally creating more splat for
every four bedroom pool that's on board
and alcohol that's four separate legible
units that's being created right we're
reimagining the living space for
individual renter right who's
traditionally getting this 500 square
feet studio apartment and now getting
access to a living room dining room
backyard in a much larger single family
space and third of all uh you know
there's this
major learning this problem i think
that's been largely really unsolved
since the you know beginning of the
pandemic uh and the way we've impacted
this is you know every single day would
create these compatible living groups uh
and so far there's been you know 1500
roommates that we've onboarded and
launched into these uh inbuilt micro
communities that's really uh you know a
great feeling for us that we see every
single day and and something that drive
us to uh you know continue to build
interesting and yeah i guess the focus
is mainly on
sort of generation z and the more the
younger generations that are more tech
savvy that are more prone to to having
trust through through digital platforms
right i mean there's there's this sort
of the old traditional ways of of
looking of looking for spaces but and
i'm guessing that also most renters and
single family homes that are looking for
bedrooms are more of the younger
generations i guess probably up to 30 40
today right
yeah i i would say so yeah our median
age on our governor's about 32 uh and so
you're generally i would say uh people
on our platform are you know 20 to 35.
uh and you know obviously we we have a
wide spectrum and i think our orders
headed at something like 87 uh and so
it's definitely not uh again it's
definitely not a narrow
um i well i i think
you know yes uh you know first of all
the
you know the digital right like um
the digital revolution you know uber
airbnb have definitely opened up uh you
know the path for us to
uh you know create this really sharing
uh roommate finding uh platform uh
that's you know completely digital uh so
that's that's that's step one right but
i think really the the macros of the
space right that you look at um yeah you
know especially where we're currently
located uh in in durham and raleigh
durham in charlotte in atlanta right
there's a 40
year-over-year roommate demand increase
uh in in the southeast uh in the sun
belt area in the southeast and so
specifically uh you know we've chosen to
focus uh you know in this area you know
not just because right like that's where
we started where we we
when i went to where my co-founder and i
went to school but also because there
really is this tailwind of this of this
micro trend that's happening you know
from culvert people you know sort of
moving out of tier 1 cities uh and you
know we've deliberately stayed away from
major cities right like new york san
francisco la these are places where you
know traditionally there's already been
a lot of young people living there right
so developers have have been able to
build a lot of studio apartments one
bedroom units to accommodate for that
you know supply demand dynamic but you
know uh these sort of uh you know outer
cities like some belt cities raleigh
durham charlotte atlanta tampa
jacksonville austin uh natural sort of a
sneak peek as to what we're looking at
next um right like these are
fast very frustrating cities with this
incredible
um
you know mismatch right a structural
inefficiency in the real estate uh
demand to its supply and you know we see
multi-family builders getting built
every single day in every single street
uh and and we need to uh we need to
continue to do that but we're not
keeping up right now uh and you know we
see it with rent prices and so uh you
know alcove is part of that solution
and uh you know that's that's sort of i
i think the combination of uh you know
the the digital aspects and the macro
aspects i think is why this is such a
great time to do this
colin thank you so much this was so
enjoyable i really loved your your
insights and the way that you're
thinking through this problem and from
both from the personal perspective all
the way to the growth of it and and to
understanding the market trends and what
needs to happen in order to
make housing more affordable more
accessible and and understanding how
your work also impacts the the supply
and demand on both sides so i'm curious
to follow your journey with alcove and
thank you very much for sharing with me
your passion and excitement for it yes i
wish you best of luck and thank you very
much for coming
thank you so much for having me michael
thank you
[Music]
you